arguably the most important and
horrifying scene in Andy muschetti's
adaptation of it is the debut of
Pennywise Stephen King's Unforgettable
Eater of Worlds spawning a thousand
memes and a thousand more nightmares the
moment when Pennywise lures Georgie
denbrough into the sewers below Dairy is
as terrifying as it is instantly
memorable and it's hard to imagine the
situation could have played out
differently but it turns out that
musketti actually directed a surprise
alternate opening for it which ends in a
very different way
while this was obviously filmed as a gag
muskete's alternate opening does provoke
some interesting thoughts about the
story if Georgie had survived
pennywise's attack it's entirely
possible that the evil demons Reign Over
the town of Derry would have continued
unchallenged after all the murder of
Georgie was the beginning of the end of
his demise even if he didn't know it at
the time